Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about building an AI vocoder
that is able to synthesize believable singing
from MIDI and lyrics as inputs.
But first, what is a vocoder?
It works kinda like this.
Fellow Scholars who are fans of Jean-Michel
Jarre's music are likely very familiar with
this effect, I've put a link to an example
song in the video description.
Make sure to leave a comment with your favorite
songs with vocoders so I and other Fellow
Scholars can also nerd out on them.
And now about the MIDI and lyrics terms.
The lyrics part is a simple text file containing
the words that this synthesized voice should
sing, and the MIDI is data that describes
the pitch, length and the velocity of each
sound.
With a little simplification, we could say
that the score is given as an input, and the
algorithm has to output the singing footage.
We will talk about the algorithm in a moment,
but for now, let's listen to it.
Wow.
So this is a vocoder.
This means it separates the pitch and timbre
components of the voice, therefore the waveforms
are not generated directly, which is a key
difference from Google DeepMind's WaveNet.
This leads to two big advantages:
One, the generation times are quite favorable.
And by favorable, I guess you're hoping for
real time.
Well, hold on to your papers, because it is
not real time, it is 10-15 times real-time!
And two, this way, the algorithm will only
need a modest amount of training data to function
well.
Here, you can see the input phonemes that
make up the syllables of the lyrics, each
typically corresponding to one note.
This is then connected to a modified WaveNet
architecture that uses 2-by-1 dilated convolutions.
This means that the dilation factor is doubled
in each layer, thereby introducing an exponential
growth in the receptive field of the model.
This helps us keep the parameter count down,
which enables training on small datasets.
As validation, the mean opinion scores have
been recorded, in a previous episode, we discussed
that this is a number that describes how a
sound sample would pass as genuine human speech
or singing.
The test showed that this new method is well
ahead of the competition, approximately midway
between the previous works and the reference
singing footage.
There are plenty of other tests in the paper,
this is just one of many, so make sure to
have a look.
This is one important stepping stone towards
synthesizing singing that is highly usable
in digital media and where generation is faster
than real time.
Creating a MIDI input is a piece of cake with
a midi master keyboard, or we can even draw
the notes by hand in many digital audio workstation
programs.
After that, writing the lyrics is as simple
as it gets and doesn't need any additional
software.
Tools like this are going to make this process
accessible to everyone.
Loving it.
If you would like to help us create more elaborate
videos, please consider supporting us on Patreon.
We also support one-time payments through
cryptos like Bitcoin, Ethereum and Litecoin.
Everything is available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!